we have seen the line with king e6 let's
just back up to where we left this game
last
and run through the moves uh and how
we got the position that we have on the
board currently
yeah actually it's a very sad moment
magnus took a lot of time i mean set for
magnus because he was already
you know we also got excited about this
that he gets a knight to e4 and then
alexander kakur it's like a machine uh
study like defensive setup
and uh after burning a lot of time
magnus didn't find anything better than
to go for this
exchange uh possession after luke casey
black has this
important vessels with luke c8 giving up
the rook
and immediately one also sees that black
can never lose the position okay white
as well can never lose the 2k one
hc rook h1 h2 on the board
king f5 g5 as well another white king
will
march his way back to g2 making sure
that the
king covers the pawn then he activates
the rook
and i believe that once they get this
position then the move
moves out they will agree to it though
because okay there is just
nothing i mean white can never make
progress and black also has no way of
playing for a win because it's it's
finally also the wrong
long corner even if he would uh
change the g pawn yeah black plays king
f5 plays g4
takes takes and then even if he would
manage to win the rook
for his e-pawn then it's still a bad
corner so no no chances for black at all
i'm just super impressed with the way
alexander donchenko has defended this
position
and it's not as if magnus made it easy
for him magnus found
all the possible questions and resources
that he had
to be able to make something in the
position but
don chanko up to the task i mean peter
such a hard position to
to be able to keep in control when we
saw this line with c4
getting this e4 square for the night we
felt it was all over for alexander
making the only moves
just it's been the day of the defense
really i mean with aryan tari getting
out alive with that position
alexander donchenko defending this very
difficult position
against magnus and i also see that
jordan
van furist has survived his nightmare
against alireza faruja another very
stronghold defense
by the dutchman yeah absolutely i mean
and also the way how he
managed you know everywhere move per
move and yeah here in the magnus game we
are
seeing an end to this game bishop takes
edge to king g5
and the draw is agreed
i mean fantastic defense